a boy dressed as a girl is accused of
raping an actual girl in the bathroom of
a school in loudoun county virginia that
boy apparently has just been found
guilty by a judge
the father of the girl who says she was
raped is called scott smith and he said
he plans to file a lawsuit against the
school system over this and that can't
come too soon at a recent school board
being the superintendent of loudoun
county schools a guy called scott
ziegler said quote we don't have any
records of assaults occurring in our
restrooms because of course they
couldn't be bothered to keep track what
does that have to do with the equity
agenda nothing what do we care about our
students nothing
so students walked out of school today
in loudoun county into protest rosiac is
with the daily wire he broke this story
and deserves the credit for it he joins
us tonight with an update luke thanks so
much for coming on
everything about this story is stomach
turning tell us where we are tonight
please
well yesterday the kid was convicted in
court of both assaults the first one
that happened in a bathroom where he was
convicted of rape
and then the second one where the school
didn't tell anyone it had happened
transferred him to a different school
and he was arrested in october 6.
so you know i broke that story on your
show a couple weeks ago and in the daily
wire and most of the media largely
ignored it because they said it was
unsubstantiated
two days ago barack obama alluded to it
while campaigning with
terry mcauliffe calling it phony
right-wing outrage
yesterday everything was substantiated
in court including a bizarre detail that
the fact that this kid was wearing a
skirt is actually central to his defense
he claims that his wristwatch got caught
on the skirt he was wearing while he was
hanging out in the girl's bathroom and
that caused inadvertent sexual contact
to occur
so barack obama who really is a
heartless monster and i'm glad that's
clear to everyone now describe the rape
of a child
as phony right-wing outrage
that this is what you know he's talking
about the parents being up in arms in
virginia and basically claiming it's all
cultural war stuff first of all i never
really cared about the fact that this is
transgender the bigger issue here is
that school districts do not have the
same priorities as parents and that's
really what teren mcauliffe hit the nail
on the head with saying you know he
doesn't think parents should be telling
schools what to teach the head of the
teachers union said something similar
this week so the issue is what's the
appropriate role for parents in schools
and the democrats seem to think they
don't have one these are our kids we're
going to raise them in these government
schools
the problem is the the main case study
that they had for this parents or bad
movement it turned out to be a total
hoax i mean this guy who was arrested
and you know he looks like a blue collar
guy he's angry at school board meeting
they thought he was a bigot maybe he was
opposed to masks the clip that the media
had the whole time of him you can hear
his wife screaming at the end as her
husband is hauled away in handcuffs my
daughter was raped in school and this is
what happened so no one asked this guy
why he was mad we also found out
this week that the white house worked
with the national school boards
association to write the letter that
called this guy and other parents
domestic terrorists which the f which
the doj then used to justify fbi
involvement
yeah so your daughter gets raped in a
school bathroom the school doesn't care
or even keep track of the rape and then
you get denounced by the president and
the doj as a domestic terrorist we're
complaining about it really does tell
you everything and we wouldn't know this
without your reporting luke rosiak thank
you
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else